حياكم الله الى نشره اخباريه من العربيه
نبداها من تحضيرات القمه العربيه الثانيه
والثلاثين في جده وهذه صور لوصول الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس الى مدينه جده
للمشاركه في القمه العربيه الثانيه
والثلاثون التي تستضيفها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه كان طبعا في استقباله لدى وصوله
الى مطار الملك عبد العزيز في جده الامير
بدر بن سلطان نائب امير منطقه مكه اذا
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس يصل في هذه
اللحظات الى مدينه جده للمشاركه في القمه
العربيه الثانيه والثلاثين التي ستنعقد
غرب السعوديه في مدينه جده كان الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي اول القاده
العرب الذين وصلوا الى مدينه جده ظهرى
اليوم للمشاركه في هذه القمه هذه اذا صور
وصول الرئيس رئيس السلطه محمود عباس صور
اذا الصور الان
التي نتابعها كانت قبل قليل لدى وصوله الى
مدينه جده السعوديه وكان في استقباله كما
نشاهد في الصوره الامير بدر بن سلطان نائب
امير منطقه مكه المكرمه منه لمتابعه
المزيج اشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات